suddenly leaves here and in this video
I'm going to be sharing with you the
seven steps to starting out in prophecy
for complete beginners even if you are a
teenager so stay tuned are you ready to
step out of your comfort zone yes have
some fun and you're gonna make some
money
you ready to save some lives yes said
the 7 steps to starting a new property
for complete beginners either if you are
a teenager I'm use a little walk I don't
want to go too far on this war club
because my wife and I lose at home them
it is a due date today so I'm faithfully
doing this video I'm not gonna watch you
funny because you might go into labor
[Music]
I'm gonna go for a walk I'll see you at
sweet pie so where do we have an hour
baby so if you're a baby beginner in
property maybe you were a teenager of 17
years old then this really is for you
you know I did a video last week and
last week it was a social experiment and
the social experiment proved that people
are super unsupportive when you're
starting out in property investing
especially if you are young so I
promised it to do a video specifically
for teenagers or people that are just
brand new starting out into property and
give you some pointers some pieces of
advice
[Music]
tip number one get into a good circle
what do I mean by that
you are the makeup of the five people
that you spend the most time with crazy
isn't it I'll say that again
you are the makeup of the five people
you spend the most time with if you're
thinking right now my goodness I need to
get some new friends you probably do now
when I started out in property I was
just literally a teenager 17 years old I
joined business networks
I attended Biennale 4 and lots of
business forums and communities where
you have breakfast together and you meet
with sophisticated business people now I
felt completely out of place like a kid
in the suit I attended property
networking events and got myself around
successful people people that understood
property and people who would take me
seriously and believed in me and if you
start doing that honestly it's gonna
have a massive impact on you you've got
friends they were holding you back that
are dragging you down then maybe you
need to start spending two minutes with
them rather than two hours or maybe two
hours instead of two days my first
property that I bought it didn't go in
my name and it wasn't my money that I
used to buy it because it's all about
who you know not what you know so step
one is get yourself in a good circle
which brings me nicely on to step two
step two is don't be intimidated by
anybody so when you start off and you're
going to these networking events and
there's these high flyers people that
are lot older than you a lot more
successful than you they know a lot more
than you don't be intimidated be
comfortable in your own skin and
remember that we always overestimate the
intelligence of others and underestimate
the intelligence of ourselves just
because someone is hour older than you
does not mean that they're a lot smarter
than you most people when they leave
school they stop learning they stop
studying they just go into a job and do
the same mundane thing day after day and
they might say they've got 20 years
experience but really they've just got
one years experience photocopy 20 times
so don't be intimidated and don't be
afraid to ask questions and look a
little bit silly sometimes it's okay if
you're a teenager then this is the time
to looks too
this is the time to us all the stupid
questions in particular be intimidated
by never day and step 3 step 3 I call
this the coffee trick what do I mean by
the coffee trick now this won't work on
me by the way so don't try this on me
there's a lot of people out there that
I've got lots of knowledge they're
successful or maybe they're just a few
steps ahead of you and rather than
paying thousands and thousands of pounds
to go on property investment programs
and courses you can literally find
someone that's a little bit ahead of you
and say now most of the time they'll be
almost you know flattered and honored
that you've asked them for a coffee and
they'll say yes they'll want to see you
do well and then you could be able to
pick their brains for the whole half an
hour or however long you meet them for
it's a way of getting free information
don't be a sponge but make the most of
the people that you know in your circle
tip number four is don't quit your job
to do property full-time now you can't
do this if you've got zero
responsibilities and no overhead say
you're living with parents and you just
want to immerse yourself in property for
you you can do this but I would really
suggest keep a full-time job even if
it's just 30 40 hours a week because
that will give you income and it'll be
easier to get a mortgage whereas if you
go full-time into property it'll be
difficult to get a mortgage it'll be
difficult to save up money and you'll
find that it will be very easy unless
you're extremely self disciplined and
motivated to slip into lazy habits you
don't want to be a bum so I would say
work full-time on your job work
part-time on your fortune and it
probably won't be very long maybe a year
or two when you can quit your full-time
job and then you can work full-time on
your fortune tip 5 write down your goals
and tell people your goals
someone once said if you haven't written
down your goals it's not a goal it's
just a dream there's a lot of people out
there with dreams there's only a few
with actual targets but you don't want
to be a dreamer you want to be a dealer
you want to be a success so write down
your goals don't be afraid to make them
quite ambitious
but at the same time you don't want it
so high in the sky that it's just not
going to happen so what I like to do is
set monthly and yearly goal so I'll say
right these are what this is want to
achieve every month and this is want to
achieve my first year once you've done
that you can then increase it and push
it up push it up push it up so when I
started out in property at 17 years old
my first goal was to just buy a house I
said I want to buy a house when I'm 18
that was my goal I did that I said right
now I want to buy and I updated update
and I am now where I am today so I'll
give you an example rather than saying I
want to be a billionaire in 10 years
time you'd be better off to say in 12
months time I want the keys in my hand
to my first buy-to-let property and tell
people that when you sit down for your
coffees after the coffee drink you say
look all I want 12 months I want the
keys in my hands on my first house
people will love to help you're cheaper
tip 6 remember that property is not the
best thing to invest in don't invest in
property invest first in you invest in
yourself the bigger you grow the bigger
your bank and your portfolio will grow
so immerse yourself in education Jim
Rohn says that formal education will
earn you a living but self education
will earn you a fortune so read all the
books read my book if you haven't
already read it buy low rent high Rich
Dad Poor Dad the e-myth is a great
business book the richest man in Babylon
fantastic around money management
secrets of millionaire mind there's
loads of books you can immerse yourself
in there's loads of courses on property
you know I've run a two-day property
investors crash course we got a lot of
young people and beginners on that they
always leave professionals so immerse
yourself in the education and subject
and field of property and finally step 7
is do whatever it takes
growing a portfolio from scratch fast is
doable but it is going to take a lot of
doing it's gonna take a lot of
discipline so if you will do what most
people are not prepared to do now then
you'll be able to do what most people
can't do in a few years time so if
you've got a drive a long way to get to
that program
if you've got to get sick up super early
to attend that networking event if
you've got to live like a pauper why you
save in order to put down some money for
a property investment then absolutely do
what you need to do now I could go into
all the technicalities of property but
you know what if you just do those seven
things you I promise you you will figure
it out
the information is out there when you
read the books attend the seminars talk
to the people you'll do it also when you
grow your circle you'll be able to
leverage other people's time other
people's knowledge and also other
people's money so hope that's been
helpful and I'd love to see you if
you're a beginner if you're just
starting out I'd love to meet you at one
of the property investors crash courses
we also run the property investors
circle well we have top speakers and
trainers come down once a month that's
held in Warsaw on the third Tuesday of
every month so do whatever it takes get
down come and meet successful folks
change your circles do not make excuses
now there's no way in a short video like
this that I could give you all the
property knowledge that you need to go
and be successful as a beginner but what
I have given you right now is I've given
you all the tools and the lifestyle
choices that you need to go and learn
everything that you need to go and be
successful in property as a beginner so
I hope you found that helpful don't
forget next week we've got our next
video I'm gonna do a video about all the
lessons that I learned from meeting up
with Arnold Schwarzenegger he's a really
cool guy I learned so much from him that
I've done a whole video dedicated to do
what I learned from meeting him so if
you want to see that don't forget to
subscribe below right now if you've got
any questions about this video then
leave them below and also I'm gonna be
meeting up with Lord Allen sugar next
month I've booked a private mentoring
dawn session with him if you've got any
questions that you'd like me to ask Kim
then comment below and I will do my best
so please do subscribe below right now
afford to seeing you next week
you've obviously not popped yet and
Amanda look at its cover face of
Christmas
see you next week
[Music]
you